vendredi dernier l'école militaire de
saint cyr a fêté ses 50 ans une
cérémonie a eu lieu avec l'ensemble des
élèves du prestigieux établissement
l'occasion pour ses dirigeants de
revenir sur son histoire sur fond de
roulement de tambour
reportage d'anne laure landi c'était il
ya cinquante ans le lycée militaire de
saint-cyr rasé en partie pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale rouvrait ses
portes sur décision du général de gaulle
une date importante que l'établissement
a tenu à commémorer une grande partie
des 750 élèves ont participé à la fête
malgré la pluie
c'est quand même un événement important
pour nous comme toute commémoration
d'ailleurs parce que justement la force
de cet établissement repose sur son
histoire et cette histoire est lourde et
chargé de sens l'école de saint cyr a vu
le jour en 1686 sous louis xiv
elle était à l'époque réservé à
l'enseignement des jeunes filles
c'est napoléon qui la transformera en
lycée militaire
aujourd'hui 70% de ces élèves sont des
enfants de militaires
si vous avez s'enliser alors peut-être
rigueur parce que c'est un mot qui
revient souvent chez les anciens élèves
qui sont partis d'établissement 100 % de
réussite au bac et une mention pour 84 %
des élèves des statistiques hors norme
qui séduisent de nombreux parents le
lycée reçoit d'ailleurs beaucoup plus de
candidatures qu'il ne peut accueillir
d'élèves
mais au delà des notes l'établissement
défend une culture du savoir être je
trouve ce pas seulement une question
d'excellence académique c'est aussi
l'excellence dans le domaine du
comportement c'est aussi l'excellence
dans le domaine du savoir être et
surtout une école qui a malgré tout
évolué même si on peut penser que son
lourd passif historique là on crée un
petit peu dans le passé et pas du tout
des méthodes pédagogiques qui sont
actuelle des enseignants qui tournait
qu'ils viennent et repartent
régulièrement de cette école et donc à
une école qui qui est qui connaît les
pédagogies de 2016 avec des tableaux
numériques qui ont remplacé des tableaux
a créé cette année le lycée de saint cyr
a ouvert des filières technologiques
un bac sti 2d et un bts réseaux et
systèmes numériques un juste équilibre
entre tradition et innovation